[Music]
apple says a digital driver's license
is coming soon rich jamiro has today's
tech smart
all this week apple is holding their
worldwide developers conference this
year's event is virtual
and it's where they're showing off their
latest software features for the iphone
and other apple products here's a look
at some of the biggest
announcements apple's worldwide
developers conference kicked off with
ceo
tim cook addressing an audience of
virtual faces
we are committed to being a force for
change as we seek to make the world a
better place
full of opportunity for all of us
this is the event where apple shows off
the latest software features coming to
the iphone
and its other devices ios 15 getting new
features to help you focus
if your phone is in do not disturb mode
it will let others know when they try to
message you
facetime getting various features to
better compete with zoom
including a grid view and links that let
others join in from
android or a web browser we recently
added more diverse siri voice options
and they sound incredible for added
privacy siri no longer needs internet
for basic functions
which means audio of your voice never
leaves your phone
and responses will be faster and the
idea of a digital driver's license
getting one step
closer to reality apple says users in
some states will be able to scan their
id by the end of the year
and store it on their phone they're
working with the tsa to make it
acceptable for travel
this is the largest data set ever used
to study fall risk
and it's helped create this first of its
kind health metric
and when it comes to health apple says
it can now use sensors in the iphone
to figure out if users are at an
increased risk of falling
family members will be able to share
their health data
with major changes highlighted finally
you'll be able to set
a legacy contact a user who gets access
to the contents of your icloud storage
when you die apple says the public will
be able to test some of these new
features
in beta as early as july but they'll
arrive as a free software update for
everyone later in the fall and the good
news is
if your phone runs ios 14 it's also
compatible
with ios 15. more on my website rich
on tech dot tv i'm rich demuro and you
are tech smart